hello everyone
i have noticed that when my students
first start learning latex
they can create their first document
without much difficulty using the many
resources available online
but there is one aspect to uh such
uh document preparation
in which they do face some difficulty
and that is the creation of the
references in a nice automatic fashion
in fact i have noticed uh some of my own
students
uh
creating this reference list manually
now that is rather unfortunate because
one of the biggest advantages of using
this wonderful typesetting environment
called latex
is that it provides a nice systematic
way of creating the reference list in a
very consistent fashion
so
uh through this example document that i
have
i have over here
let me demonstrate to you how we can
create this reference list automatically
in a nice clean and easy way so let's
get to the bottom of the document
where we have this reference list so you
want to have something like this
prepared automatically cleanly and
quickly
so what we need for this is basically
two things first of course we need the
dot tech file
and we also need a bibliography file so
these are two separate files
there are ways to combine them together
but
for the sake of beginning
these things let's keep them separate
so on the left hand side i'm using this
terminal i'm on a linux machine but
whatever i'm going to discuss applies
equally well to
windows i do not have any experience
with
mac but
i hear that max mac is based on unix so
it should be quite similar to linux so
it should work on all platforms and uh
and whatever i'm doing here it'll work
equally well whether you have make tech
or tech live as your compiler for latex
so
let's take a look at the files that are
there in this folder this is the tech
demo folder i have just created for the
demonstration purpose
so
uh we have three files here uh
so this points.tech
this is the tech file
uh points.pdf which is just this file
over here on the right
and the refs.wav file which is the
bibliography file
so
let me just increase the font size a
little bit
okay
so
we will first take a look at the
bibliography file
so i using vim as my editor but you can
use anything that you want nano uh
even notepad will work okay
so uh
so this is my bibliography file i
already have a list of references and
please note very importantly that
this is the first reference
so this is like a database of references
all right
so
the first reference that we have here
this is
einstein's famous paper or one of
einstein's famous papers
there is no direct correspondence
between the ordered in which it is
placed here in this database
and the order in which it appears here
okay so this can be independently
controlled uh
based on what we do uh and what we write
in our dot tag file
okay so this really is like a database
okay
it just has the information regarding
the references
so this is just for demonstration
purpose uh for actually learning how to
do this what i'm going to do is
show you that if i have an actual paper
that i have obtained by browsing the
internet
how i can transfer the information from
that paper
into such a this this file
and then uh
actually incorporate that as part of my
document okay so we'll go through this
process
and that will be a complete overview so
let me get out of this file
and just take a look quickly at the
points.tech file the text file actually
okay so i am not going to go into the
details of this file itself the only
thing which i will point out here
is
you note
this particular line
okay
so this one
maybe i can zoom in a little bit more
this
line in highlighted red
backslash use package nad bib okay so
i'm using this thing
it provides quite a bit of flexibility
in creating various kinds of referencing
reference list citation styles
so that's good
let me get to the bottom of this
document
so this is the bottom of the document
we have two lines over here
the backslash bibliography
within curly brackets i have written
this agsm
so this is a particular kind of
referencing style or citation style
and the thing that you see over here you
see there's a certain formatting first
we have the names of the authors then we
have the year name then we have the
title of the paper followed by the
journal name the volume number and the
page number so this particular style is
is embedded within this agsm style
okay we don't have to get into any more
details at this point
and this next line that you see
backslash bibliography
refs so this
line basically tells the system which
file to refer to
for the database of the
citation uh
for the database of the citations so the
previous file that we had looked at that
was the refs.bib file we do not have to
write refs.bev here just the name of
that bibliography file is sufficient so
these are the two lines here at the
bottom that i'm using we may put this at
the beginning also no problem
but i like to keep this at the bottom
and
so that's it so in the beginning we have
that nat bib
line and here we have these two lines
so now what i'm going to do is
i'm going to get out of this
document again
back in the terminal now but
uh i have already opened in my browser
so let me move to my workspace
containing the browser so i have this
paper open in front of me
okay so you can search for any paper
that you want
and once you get it
you can
transfer this information directly into
the
the bibliography file in a very easy way
so
what you do is just select the title
copy this thing
and then
go to scholar.google.com
and within double quotes
just paste the title
enter
so
this is a rather famous
paper uh
in the area of lithium and batteries so
you see
let me just zoom in here
you see there is this little
site
link here
if we click on that
it'll
show up with this dialog box
and
here at the bottom you can see
this bib deck
so this is the one that we want now if
we click on this bibtex
it will
show us
this particular format of the
information which is associated with
that paper automatically i have not done
anything i've just clicked on those
things
okay so what we can do is we can just
copy it from here
just ctrl c
and then i get back to my
workspace where i was working and then i
open i reopen the
bibliography file
okay here it is i'll reduce the font
size a little bit
and then i'll just get to the bottom of
this okay or i can just put it anywhere
it doesn't matter
okay
so
i just paste it here
now you see
all the things are present here the
title the author
journal name
sorry
i mean
this thing is not properly written here
sometimes
google can mess up a little bit
but we'll keep it like this for the time
being
uh
we have these things
now you please note that these all these
things are rather uh i mean fixed
information
you don't get to play around with this
thing uh
see the actual name of the journal
should have been nature here but google
has kind of messed up here a little bit
so you need to apply your human
intelligence a little bit and not just
depend on the artificial intelligence of
google so
since this thing is bugging me a little
bit what i'll do is i'll
replace this
thing with the proper journal name okay
now i'm happy
uh
and we don't need this publisher name
actually
it's no use
okay
i saved this thing
now you please note that
this particular
thing is referred to as the tag of this
reference and this tag also has been
created by google
automatically we do not need to
use this okay so i have my own style of
uh
tagging the various papers as you can
see here
all the all the all the different papers
i have tagged in a certain style
so i'll do like that okay so it's
completely up to us i mean if you want
you can call it tiger rabbit
anything okay it doesn't matter as long
as you remember it and use it in your
actual text file correctly it should be
absolutely fine but if you maintain a
proper professional system it'll it'll
help you in the long run so
i name it like this
okay so
save it and then i can get out of this
thing
uh remembering that the tag for this is
actually this and that thing 2011 nature
tarascon
okay i'm going to use this tag
when citing this paper from within my
dot text file okay so let me get out of
this
i'll open the points.teg file which is
my actual text file and then somewhere
uh within this maybe somewhere near the
bottom
uh i'll cite this so
let me get to this thing
so just before the references page
uh let me put this uh thing so let me
let me write a sentence a very important
paper
in the area of
of lithium ion batteries
is
so we write
this as
uh side t and i'll tell you in a moment
what this is
uh
but i'll first use my tag
so 2011 nature
telescope this is the same tag that i
had used in my
bibliography file
so
let me save this thing
okay
now
uh
we want see after i have saved it
nothing really happens here okay now it
is possible within the latex system to
have auto compilation
but that's a slightly advanced thing
we don't want to get into that at this
moment
rather i will
discuss this
using the steps which a beginner would
do
and that should be good enough for us
now
so let me get out of this
and now i'll issue a few commands which
will help us to compile this thing and
if i've done everything correctly it
should not give us any error so the
first thing is that
we
we write the pdf let later
points if you want you can write
points.text but if you just write points
it should be fine so i'll just write it
for the sake of completeness pedophile
points.text and enter
okay so as you can see it gives a
certain warnings kind of thing
okay
so
when you first learn uh when you first
run pdf latex after you have
incorporated a new citation it will give
you this sort of warning
okay now
what we need to do is to run
bibtex so
so
let me
increase the font size a little bit here
so you can see clearly the command is
bibtex
and then we write points which is the
name of the dot text file but instead of
writing dot tag we write dot aux
now
uh
you may be wondering what is this aux
file and where did it come from so
before actually issuing this command let
me demonstrate to you
what are the contents of this folder
currently
so
so previously we had seen that we just
had the points.pdf
which is this pdf file on the right
we had this
points.txt file and we had the refs.bib
file but after we have run the pdf latex
uh
points.txtx command
it has automatically generated this
points.ex file and of course this log
file
so this auxiliary file this aux
auxiliary file that is created this is
the one which we are supposed to use
along with our bibtex command
so
bibtex
points dot aux
okay so this is good news these lines
are just like messages they are not
warnings or errors
it means that it has run properly
without any errors without any problems
and now
uh
we have to
use the pdf latex command
two more times so it's just the way that
it is
i mean it works so
we have to run this
once
and then we have to run it one more time
okay so
uh
actually
if you are on a
on a windows machine
and
you are using something like
adobe reader
then
whatever just happened on the right hand
side here will not happen
okay in fact if your pdf file is open
you will not even be able to
use the pdf latex
command so every time you need to
run this thing
you will have to close your pdf from
your ad up reader
and then only you can run it
however even on windows you can get a
similar sort of behavior that i'm
getting here on linux
if you use a pdf reader
which is perfectly free called sumatra
pdf
so give that a try uh what i'm using
here on
uh on my lx machine here so this pdf
reader uh which is absolutely bare bones
uh
you don't see any fills at the top or
anything
uh you can can't even see a scroll bar
here so this pdf reader is a it's a very
simple one it's called zathura
if you're on linux
you can give it a try
but the most important thing which i
have not mentioned here is that after we
have
run our commands on the left hand side
in the terminal
this tarascon paper
paper by tarascon and armand it has
appeared here automatically okay nowhere
in our text file
did i write
any information with my hand using this
thing
okay
the only place where i mentioned the
status con is when i use that tag that
is the only manual thing that i had to
do and of course that you have to do
because as part of the sentence it is up
to you where you cite a particular paper
okay
so
so this is it basically so if you can
include one reference you can include
any number of references any number of
times
okay
and let's just take a look
at
what has happened within the text
so if we scroll up
we can see that we have this sentence
over here
which is the one that i had typed in
before
starting the compilation process
a very important paper in the area of
lithium and batteries is status quo and
armament
now if we just compare with what we have
in our
actual text file
i'll go to the bottom
you see the sentence was a very
important paper in the area of
lithuanian batteries is
site t
this tag of the citation
okay so
latex has actually done
an important part of our
job for us
by
writing
this tarascon and almond automatically
for us together with the yearn number uh
with the year
all right so
uh this is a very uh i mean very very
convenient way and after learning this i
believe no student will ever try to do
this thing manually